[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
colombia en la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales que enfrenta
este domingo al izquierdista gustavo
petro con el populista rodolfo hernández
para ello me acompañan en este estudio
tres invitados les presento ya cristo
aventura es director de investigación en
el instituto iris especializado en
latinoamérica venido christophe muchas
gracias buenos días
camille wood con investigador en el
instituto de investigación estratégica
de la escuela militar en el polo defensa
y sociedad y además ha trabajado en el
papel de las mujeres en la construcción
de la paz bienvenida a cambio muchas
gracias claros y nos acompaña también el
y sequeira es coordinador de la red
francia colombia solidaridad y animador
en francia para el programa vamos por la
paz bienvenido ya encantado carlos
colombia en la decisión del cambio pero
que cambio hoy es nuestro asunto en
primera plana
colombia quiere cambio en su destino
político eso está claro lo que hace
falta saber ahora es hacia dónde se
dirige ese cambio la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales enfrenta
este domingo al izquierdista petro
frente al populista rodolfo hernández el
que algunos llaman el tram colombiano
las encuestas están muy ajustadas casi
imposibles ya estos días de ver una
tendencia clara los indecisos pueden
tener la llave de la casa de nariño
vamos a analizar a fondo lo que suponen
estas elecciones para la historia del
país pero antes veamos algunas portadas
que nos deja la prensa diario 'el
espectador' el dilema del cambio tras la
primera vuelta colombia votó cambio pero
ahora se enfrenta a ese dilema de cambio
con dos opciones bien distintas
semana los petro vídeos ese escándalo de
grabaciones reveladas por este semanario
que afecta al candidato de la izquierda
sobre cómo supuestamente idearon planes
de campaña para destruir a sus
adversarios políticos en new york times'
el trump colombiano podría ganar las
presidenciales dice el rotativo
estadounidense que con su verbo
incendiario hernández podría acaparar
los votantes de la derecha que tanto
recelan de petró pero no sé si dirían
que estamos ante las elecciones más
inciertas o al menos de las más
inciertas de la historia reciente del
país en las que casi todo puede pasar
christophe si claramente las más
inciertas de la historia del siglo 20
de colombia porque por dos razones la
primera es que es la prima la primera
vez que la izquierda
alcanzó un resultado tan importante hay
que recordarse que gustavo petro por la
primera presencia la izquierda en la
segunda vuelta colombiana fue en el 2018
obtuvo 25 por ciento del voto hoy en la
primera vuelta
obtuvo más de 40 es un fenómeno
increíble que no significa la victoria
de petró en la segunda pero ya eso es
una cosa inédita la segunda inédita es
la derrota del uribismo como tal de la
derecha tradicional que haga que el
gobierno durante décadas en esos 20
últimos años con uribe y que por la
primera vez no estará como tal en la
segunda vuelta con la emergencia de
fernández hay que saber si eres una
nueva propuesta a la continuidad del
pasado con una nueva cara eso es una
cuestión también inédita para colombia
está claro que hay una ruptura de la
inercia histórica del país hay dos
posibilidades de cambio son antagónicas
que claves pueden decantar la balanza de
uno u otro lado camino
yo creo que estamos en frente de los
candidatos bastante diferentes porque en
el caso de petro por ejemplo tenemos un
trabajo político que se está
construyendo desde muchísimos años
tenemos
diputados tenemos congresistas que han
sido elegidos en las elecciones
legislativas en marzo
frente a hernández quien un poco sale de
la nada entre comillas ambos están en
rupturas pero ambos son muy distintos y
muy diferentes en su ruptura entonces
finalmente la clave va a ser qué tipo de
ruptura realmente va a hablar airoso de
los electores vale
también está el hecho bueno como clave
no está el reciente la reciente decisión
del tribunal de bogotá que los ha
llamado a participar en un debate
de cierta forma no no de cierta forma ha
habido un desacato el grande el debate
ha habido un desacato de esta decisión
judicial y entonces estamos a la
expectativa de ver cuál va a ser el
resultado de esto por una parte es que
hernández perdóname ya lee muchas ganas
de debatir parece que no tenía no en lo
absoluto y de hecho parece un poco
vale que es complejo porque petro ha
reaccionado bastante bien ante como los
comunicados que el lanzador raúl
fernández recordemos para los oyentes o
telespectadores que se sientan un poco
perdidos con este asunto
digamos que el candidato hernández había
establecido una cantidad de condiciones
leoninas para poder asistir a ese debate
que se celebrará en bucaramanga la
ciudad de la que fue alcalde bueno una
serie de cantidades de cantidades
temáticas y respeto a los periodistas
petro cogió el guante y aceptó todas las
condiciones y finalmente no se ha
celebrado ese debate no se ha celebrado
ese debate pese que petro se decía
presto a realizarlo y pues el candidato
rodolfo hernández simplemente he dicho
de que el comunicado de petro era muy
vago y que por eso no iba a ir al debate
algunas claves más que queréis aportar
christophe de que puede depender hay dos
millones de indecisos como pueden
moverse estos votos de gente que todavía
no tenga decidido el candidato yo creo
que es eso
indecisos son claramente la
clave de la segunda vuelta porque si
pensamos el tema a partir de los
resultados de la primera de vuelta es
claro que la adición de los votos de la
derecha uribista de federico gutiérrez
es más el voto del centro de fajardo
etcétera tienen casi 11 millones de
votos cuando petro obtuvo
8.5 y no hay muchas reservas pero
digamos que él perdona cristo los votos
de la derecha de fico entendemos que se
han ido ya al campo de rodolfo los de
fajardo los aumentó no está tan claro
esto yo creo que el voto de fajardo lo
mejor no está tan clara no está tan
claro es porque su incierto es no está
tan claro pero supuestamente habrá una
repartición el voto del centro con uno o
el otro el tema es que si sabemos que
detrás del voto adolfo primero de todo
tenemos el voto revista tradicional que
es el mismo que votó masivamente para
hernández hay que subrayarlo es el
centro de colombiano y el este del país
que votó para el es el voto del campo
uribista sobre todo bueno entonces yo
creo que la clave son los individuos
porque hubo como 45 por ciento de
abstención en la primera vuelta es aquí
que vamos a ver si hay una movilización
desde esa esa abstención en términos de
jóvenes que se van a hacer y de nosotros
también si hay una movilización por
quien se va a ir a esa movilización
porque las encuestas estamos un empate
técnico
1 48 47 46 48 pico y bueno eso es porque
no tenemos que si les pregunto una cosa
hablamos de encuestas muy ajustadas
la cantidad de polémicas que ha habido
en esta campaña no hay un riesgo de que
el lunes el campo perdedor no acepte los
resultados si estuvieran muy ajustados y
colombia se metiera en una espiral muy
peligrosa este riesgo real de lo
pregunto sólo recordar que hay lo que
podemos conseguir es un empobrecimiento
también de la calidad del debate porque
lo que venimos viendo desde hace semana
es que se ha hablado más en términos de
ataques personales y no tanto a nivel
programático no entonces eso hay que
tenerlo en cuenta ya a nivel de la
aceptación de los resultados
hay probabilidades de que haya
movilización social a raíz de si gana
uno o el otro en los dos casos en los
dos casos en los dos casos así es va a
depender mucho de la diferencia que haya
es decir a lo mejor una diferencia así
que legitime un resultado pero el
momento que salga muy ajustado puede
verla petro ha llamado ya como
advertencia sobre probabilidades de
fraude lo que el cn ya le ha llamado la
atención también como diciéndole usted
tendrá que aceptar sí o sí los
resultados de la elección y por otra
parte vemos que hay como mucho más
antagonismo y visceralidad por así
decirlo por parte del electorado que va
detrás de raúl fernández por lo que si
se pone la pregunta y hay probabilidades
pero esperemos que que se acepta unos
resultados también como lo ven yo creo
que habrá mucha inestabilidad
en el caso de que gane hernández por
ejemplo tiene un proceso judicial que
pasa el 21 de julio entonces hay mucha
incertidumbre
inestabilidad ese eventualmente un
factor de estadio social
yo lo veo más problemas siguen a
hernández que si lo contrario no sé por
qué pero tal vez es más una es una
presunción mía de repente pero me parece
que del lado de petro estamos frente a
movimientos sociales más organizados y
anclados de repente no va a haber un
estadio y al día siguiente pero sí con
esa historia de proceso judicial y todo
es probable que yo veo más más
inestabilidad incertidumbre
en los próximos meses que estadio ya con
mucha violencia
christophe el uribismo que usted
mencionaba hacia referencia sobre todo
la erosión del gobierno de iván duque
que perjudicaron sin duda al candidato
conservador fico gutiérrez eliminado en
primera vuelta como se han movido esos
apoyos ahora hacia el campo de hernández
porque hernández durante este período ha
intentado desligarse mucho de sus apoyos
del uribismo el apoyo del uribismo es
bajo cuerda está citó está detrás o
siempre lo ha estado bueno mía quince
minutos después del reconocimiento de su
derrota a federico cuchara es llamó sus
electores a votar masivamente por
rodolfo hernández diciendo que la
primera amenaza para colombia se llamaba
gustavo petro con el tema del casco
chavismo y se tenga ese tema así que hay
claramente una organización del voto en
colombia hay también dinámicas de
clientelismo local regional en el cual
se organizan apoyos de votos al partido
de los caciques locales
eso se está organizando hay una
maquinaria así electoral que concierne a
todos los candidatos y el uribismo está
en marcha porque porque con adolfo
hernández el gilismo tiene la
oportunidad oportunidad de quedarse al
poder
hay un cambio desde la estructura del
poder en colombia con el resultado que
vamos a conocer el lunes si es juego de
hernández habrá un cambio de la
estructura del poder pero los mismos
sectores estarán todavía al poder con
gustavo petro sería otro otro camino así
que están organizando las cosas para
para hernández obviamente anand es en su
comunicación política no tiene interés
en presentarse como el candidato de la
continuidad
se dice que es el antisistema pero la
verdad es que cada uno tiene su word y
hernández necesita a la derecha y el
organismo al congreso porque él no tiene
ninguna no te diputado senador nada
tiene que gobernar con un grupo una
bancada y eso es el trabajo de la
derecha se ha desmarcado hernández
acción del uribismo durante esta campaña
al menos los intentos han sido claros
principal no lo que de hecho como lo
recalca existo es muy paradójico que fin
de cuentas sea como la laddh uribista
que voy a aportarle la mayor cantidad de
votos rodolfo se presenta como un
candidato de ruptura un candidato anti
establecimiento y según su bueno su
programa en el cpc para él la solución
es hacer un cambio de la clase política
colombiana no él quiere como presentarse
como alguien exterior a esto porque si
se ven temas del lenguaje no el se
presenta como un ingeniero el ingeniero
rodolfo entonces él quiere como parecer
como un outsider por así decirlo y claro
desmarcarse de esto pero al final como
lo decía cristo él va a necesitar el
uribismo para poder gobernar en seguida
vamos a continuar analizando esta
segunda vuelta de las elecciones en
colombia hacemos una breve pausa
continuamos aquí en primera plana
[Música]
enlace del conosur a norteamérica de los
andes' a centroamérica una cita semanal
con los temas más importantes de los
países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 cada
semana santiago lópez recibe en su mesa
a personalidades para debatir un tema de
actualidad que es necesario mejor
momento es una respuesta xstrata dos
políticos especialistas periodistas
artistas o activistas se reúnen durante
casi una hora para exponer sus puntos de
vista en eeuu y creo que cambio
plenamente el concepto de las relaciones
internacionales todos los temas están
permitidos ahora yo no voy a responder a
insultos y descalificación participé en
el debate a través de las redes sociales
con el hashtag el debate este 24
acompáñenme en el debate por france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana hemos puesto el foco en colombia
y vamos estamos intentando ver claves
que definan esta votación entre el
izquierdista gustavo petro y el
populista rodolfo hernández nos acompaña
en cristal pintura de un director de
investigación del instituto iris
especializado en latinoamérica y el y
siqueira coordinador de la red
solidaridad de francia colombia en la
escuela de paz camille wood con
investigador en el instituto de
investigación estratégica de la escuela
militar en el pueblo de defensa y
sociedad en colombia voto cambio eso
estaba claro en su inercia histórica en
la primera en la primera vuelta esa
demanda de cambio que ahora se puede
expresar de dos formas distintas en el
balotaje es lo que definió el voto en la
primera vuelta empezó por usted camille
esa necesidad esa ansia de cambio que
tiene el país yo creo que si colombia
tiene varias olas de movilizaciones
sociales desde el 2019 hay todo el
asunto del acuerdo de paz de las
negociaciones o sea hay muchísimas cosas
y que dejan aspirar a la gente a
transformación de sus sedes políticas
muy profundas que no realmente pasan
entonces hay una ansiedad de cambio
que no solamente es colombia es toda la
región además si vemos los países
vecinos
entonces sí hemos visto bueno a nivel
internacional el proceso de paz ha sido
algo a lo que los medios hemos dedicado
muchísimo llegó un presidente iván duque
que no ha hecho muchos esfuerzos por él
pese a ello él ha continuado el proceso
de paz como algo que ya no se puede
parar y cómo va a continuar el proceso
de paz sea rodolfo hernández o sea
gustado petro el nuevo presidente de
colombia cuál va a ser el futuro del
acuerdo de paz christophe filial quien
quiera
pues la verdad es que es un tanto
incierto por el lado de la campaña del
candidato rodolfo pues no ha habido
muchos avances o en todo caso como a
nivel programático explicaciones de cómo
él acompañaría sin embargo en redes
sociales él ha dicho que sí apoyaría el
acuerdo de paz por el parte de petro
pues esto es un poquito más claro nivel
programático se necesitarían muchísimos
esfuerzos también pongo para poder
superar la situación tan grave que ha
llegado la crisis humanitaria en
colombia actualmente
el principio del gobierno del presidente
iván duque han habido ochocientos
cincuenta y nueve asesinatos de líderes
sociales hay un balance social que es
bastante crítico y se necesita como un
gran compromiso por cualquiera de los
dos que vaya a ganar para poder sacar
adelante esto lo que sí es cierto es que
ambos han dicho querer como en tomar
negociaciones con él ln entonces
esperamos de que esto sea cierto y que
hay una verdadera voluntad política para
llegar a esto vamos con polémicas de
ambos lados o acusaciones de ambos lados
del lado de petro las acusaciones por
excelencia que siempre se le echan en
cara que es la venecia lización del país
el discurso de que colombia con la
izquierda se va a transformar en la
nueva venezuela este discurso cada vez
cada menos cada vez tiene menos
verosimilitud christo entre la opinión
pública bueno yo estuve en colombia
durante la
primera vuelta y hay que decir que este
tema todavía forma parte todavía de la
cantante de la comentario
de la
oposición a petro sin duda es todavía
hay una polarización super fuerte que
cristaliza el personaje de gustavo petro
no es viajero gasto chavismo
sovietización de colombiano se que
obviamente de una manera racional parece
un poquito exagerado un poco todo eso
pero es un
[Música]
argumento que sirve yo creo yo a
preparar a una posible movilización a
una especie de tomada de la calle una
llamado también a las fuerzas armadas en
caso de victoria de la izquierda para no
aceptarla eso crea una especie de
ambiente para que pueda
facilitar finalmente una cierta
violencia política continuamos con más
polémicas del lado de rodolfo no le
pasan factura sus gran cantidad de
expresiones sexistas machistas hay una
normalización en colombia de este tipo
de expresiones camille porque puede
parecer pero desde luego hay cosas que
ha dicho que no lo son tanto las
desigualdades de género son
estructurales como
siempre expresiones que dicho el
candidato que se toman a veces como
cierta con cierta gracia no como si
fuera un chascarrillo no si es verdad
pero si miran las últimas horas los
últimos días me parece que hay una
especie de revuelta porque el voto de
las mujeres es
1.200.000 algo así más que los hombres
les hablabas de clave para elsa la
segunda vuelta y el voto de las mujeres
va a ser clave y no es un voto tan fácil
porque no todas las mujeres son de
movimientos feministas progresistas que
van con petro con cuestiones de defensa
de los derechos de personas en gmt y
esas cosas también hay mujeres
conservadoras
que cree en los valores familiares
tradicionales entonces yo creo que ambos
candidatos cada uno a su manera intentan
atraer el voto de las mujeres que puede
hacer la diferencia claramente eso es
muy interesante
pero tienen que no pueden escoger un
bando tienen que atraer a todas y decir
cosas contrarias entonces más bien que
ver cosas sexistas de uno y del otro no
lo veo esa estrategia que desde los 23
últimos días sabiendo que petro tampoco
es un ángel o sea al momento de hacer
las listas de las elecciones
legislativas hay tres mujeres que se
sacaron de las listas a fines del año
pasado porque juzgaban que no tenían
lugar entonces
discursos pero también prácticas
petro se llegó al debate feminista es
decir que 30 organizaciones de mujeres
que como quedaron a varias organizaron
un debate feminista el 2 de junio que
supuestamente tenían que llegar ambos y
solamente llegó petro entonces al final
fue más de una entrevista pero ese tema
es realmente importante yo creo que no
es suficientemente hablado galindo
también quedó en su retórica y elementos
del lenguaje él se ha basado sobre todo
en mensajes muy cortos en redes sociales
como pueden ser de tick tock o etcétera
y frente a esto hay un candidato que
tiene es un académico también entonces
que tal vez tendrá un poquito más de
densidad y a la hora de hablarle como a
la población parece ser que bueno los
mensajes cortos y efectivistas de
hernández han marcado más la pauta
pero es una campaña en redes sociales en
el mundo digital digamos muy muy
interesante a la hora de estudiar porque
por ejemplo el otro día ayer mismo
rodolfo el señor rodolfo no quería ir al
debate pero seguía en twitter y en tick
tock explicando cuáles eran las mujeres
de su vida seguía haciendo campaña de
una forma muy intensa curioso
que es una campaña sucia films es una
campaña sobre ataque permanente sobre la
gente los o líderes
el último con la semana compre los otros
vídeos etcétera es una campaña que
sorprende mucho cuando desde cerca el
campo del otro que se le han intentado
hacer daño lógico las filtraciones se
prueban a ellos
y claro y eso obviamente a
el cáncer a todo debate de fondo sobre
las orientar jazz y los proyectos y eso
es quizás lo que quieren algunos
comunicadores como afectó el estallido
social vivido en el país
bueno lo vivimos a partir de cali como
se encendió luego y que fue tan
reprimido cómo ha influido ese estallido
social en estas elecciones como se ha
visto reflejado bueno principalmente
diría que en términos de voto de la
población más joven de los 18 a los 34
años según la última ponderación de
encuestas hay un voto que está más
dirigido hacia petro que estaría como
imagen línea con las demandas sociales
del paro nacional de 2021 además de esto
la gran cantidad de violencia de
reportes de las ideas y de otras
organizaciones internacionales que
apuntan a la violencia de organismos
como el smart o la policía nacional con
muchas ex acciones no habían sido
aceptadas para nada por el gobierno
actual y petro dentro de sus promesas
está la supresión también del smart
entonces de este escuadrón esto entra
bastante en línea
y como ya también como en todo lo que es
el acuerdo de paz esto también tiene que
seguir avanzando y del lado de rodolfo
pues el de cierta manera también apoyo
al paro pero pues lo que se está
buscando ahora en términos de respuestas
es garantías para la partida
participación política de las personas
hay algo muy grave carlos que está
pasando ahora y es el hecho de que el
día de ayer y de anterior se han
empezado a hacer las estaciones de
líderes jóvenes sociales que han
participado de manera fuerte en el paro
nacional y teniendo este fenómeno a dos
días de las elecciones eso nosotros como
organizaciones sociales tenemos bastante
miedo de que sea una manera de ejercer
presión sobre la juventud justamente
para que no haya ningún tiempo de
reacción por su parte es que a raíz de
lo que hice si alguien está en todas
estas polémicas que han envuelto la
campaña si hay algo que se ha puesto de
manifiesto y sobre todo como primer
responsable es la falta de neutralidad
institucional que debe de tener el
gobierno de ban duque que se ha puesto
muy en tela de juicio
respecto de neutralidad irreprochable
que tienen que tener las instituciones
de un gobierno con la procuraduría con
un montón de ha dejado mucho que desear
la verdad porque
de manera general ha habido muy poca
voluntad política para poder discutir
con sociedad civil los intercambios son
casi inexistentes diría yo en términos
del seguimiento del acuerdo en términos
de garantías se miró que se reunieron
durante el paro nacional hasta cierto
punto y el gobierno iván duque se sentó
con el comité de paro pero imposible de
llegar a algún tipo de acuerdo ante las
reivindicaciones que son múltiples y no
es solamente por la crisis sanitaria
causado por el comité sino por una
gestión dudosa de ellos ha habido como
un confinamiento excesivamente largo
cuando la mayoría de la población tiene
una economía informal de lo que como
resultado tiene que hay cada vez menos
posibilidades para la población sobre
todo en medios rurales de poder acceder
como educación a la financiación y lo
que puede también promover como una re
movilización o en todo caso fomentar
como una salida de la vida política como
tal y llegar como más me queda muy
poquito tiempo pero les quiero preguntar
a los tres colombia va a salir muy
fracturada estas elecciones y
seguramente muy polarizada como se
arregla esta fractura social a partir
del lunes con el presidente que hay a
partir del lunes que lamentablemente yo
creo que no tenemos que esperar eso
porque colombia entró en esa campaña
como un país muy fragmentado polarizado
mucho muchísimo y hay que entender que
hablamos de un país en el cual hay
varios países
eso es el tema contracturas etcétera
etcétera y yo creo que cualquier sea el
próximo presidente de colombia habrá un
problema de gobernar y de gobernabilidad
porque también hablamos de un país en el
cual muchos territorios están fuera del
control del estado
controlados por grupos armados narcos
guerrillas etcétera
hay el tema de la frontera con venezuela
que ha sido un poquito un tema de la
campaña más que del acuerdo de paz un
poquito pero yo creo que la
gobernabilidad de colombia no saldrá
fortaleza fortalecerá después de la
elección estará súper complicado por uno
y por el otro una frase para acabar
camille para a partir del lunes que este
programa de gobernabilidad yo estoy
totalmente de acuerdo los temas de esa
compañía central estuvieran divididos en
la seguridad en el territorio es que
hacer ver la violencia esos temas
desaparecieron por eso se usa tanto tick
tock facebook jajaja porque tú hablamos
de realmente el bus que está ahí y lo
que está ahí será ahí el lunes quien sea
que bueno pues muchísimas gracias a los
tres acción muy interesante y veremos lo
que pasa este domingo en colombia y como
como encara el país su futuro a partir
del lunes con un nuevo presidente a
todos ustedes hasta la próxima semana en
primera plana gracias
[Música]
ah